hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans la plaie
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger
on va parler maintenant des victoires de
la musique alors 2,9 millions de
téléspectateurs qui rit c'est plutôt
faiblard faiblarde par rapport à la
concurrence ce soir là c'est un peu
mieux que l'année dernière mais ce
n'était pas le même jour et par là même
concurrencer exactement alors cette
année les artistes ont fait le show sur
le plateau des victoires regardez oui
gilles verdez excusez moi mais vous ça
fait un petit moment que je vous regarde
[Applaudissements]
question vous connaissez ce monsieur ah
oui j lo valérie benaïm vous pouvez
venir une minute venez voir qu'est-ce
qui s'occupe qu'est-ce qui s'occupe de
cyril hanouna normalement c'est vous
mokhtar qu'est ce qui se passe ce
monsieur n'est pas cyril hanouna ces
messieurs n'est pas cyril hanouna
c'est le toucher le toucher le nom mais
il lui ressemble et c'est lui mokhtar il
est où cyril hanouna ce monsieur est un
artiste transformiste
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mm
c'est la même barbe regardez c'est la
même barbe touche et toucher la balle et
cyril hanouna il est beau le monsieur il
est pas beau la s'est passé récemment ne
s'est pas cyril hanouna
je vous assure regardez regardez les
cheveux mes cheveux c'est non c'est non
c'est pas la même texture même la voix
c'est pas lui le corps le corps filet ou
cyril mais aussi mais c'est un artiste
transformiste vous le connaissez pas
chaque touche comment il s'appelle
regard des embauches mais je ne sais pas
comment il s'appelle un an c'est luis
roca sa voix à la voir ça en tout cas ça
c'est magnifique
oui merci bien moooh gilou
alors nous sommes dans les victoires de
la musique et cette année les artistes
ont fait le show sur le plateau j'ai
vous avez vu les victoires de la musique
oh oui alors il y avait un duo de
présentateurs mais c'était deux nuls
[Musique]